the NSU Spyder debuted at the 1963
Frankfurt Motor Show and it caused
something of a commotion NSU announced
it would start production within a year
with a plan three to five thousand units
annually loving attention to detail made
it an instant classic the Spyder listed
at an impressive 8,500 darhk's or some
4,200 euros but once the initial uproar
had died down the two-seater convertible
was widely ignored by the German market
after months of delay in September 1964
NSU raffled off the first one off the
assembly line to an employee
the fuel tank and radiator were mounted
in front the engine and back that gave
the engineers an optimal weight
distribution the engines small size
allowed for a second trunk space a
unique feature at the time humming
underneath almost like a turbine was the
50 horsepower Wankel engine
I mean powder was assigned to work on
the rotary engine and NS use R&D
division he has fond memories of the
project and the advantages of the rotary
concept in the mid-1950s
NSU had already designed its kkm engine
with a static housing based on Felix
Wankel original dkm rotary engine design
and a spinning housing but the engine
that was to carry the Wankel name
perform noticeably better explains that
the Wankel engines mass is balanced a
great advantage over the reciprocating
piston engine which is harder to balance
the vibration is always carried over to
the vehicle and a rotary engine by
contrast there's hardly any vibration
inside the car the car just takes off
with the engine purring like an electric
motor
another benefit was the power density or
the performance potential the
reciprocating piston engines of the time
were somewhat weaker so the rotary
engine offered some advantages there to
this one so the argumentative man hotter
and ns you had high hopes for the Wankel
engine
Arman bata remembers it well the
designer suggested building a roadster
with it because the engine was so small
it could be rear mounted so the car
would have trunk space in front and room
for another storage space over the
engine and back that's the design Spyder
went ahead with it was the first car
that went into series production with a
Wankel engine following the partition
sealing a gun this the engine was
extremely high revving and compared to
other small engines very smooth
revolutions about 6,000 per minute were
no problem from the mechanical
standpoint but over longer periods the
cooling system couldn't keep up the
Spyder could run from 0 to 100 km/h and
14 and a half seconds unlike the NSU ro
80 the Spyder had a 500cc single rotor
Wankel engine with fuel consumption
rated at 10 liters per hundred
kilometers it all seemed so promising
NSU set out to write automotive history
but it just didn't work the apex seals
on the combustion chambers kept wearing
out for some time NSU was very obliging
when it came to fixing the many problems
but the cars image suffered the original
goal of five thousand spiders per year
soon proved utopian the market never
materialized and the first year of
production NSU sold only 151 units by
comparison 1965 was a good year with 923
sales by the time production was halted
in 1967 only 2375 spiders had been sold
today it's a rarity and the fact that
it's the world's first series produced
car with a Wankel engine makes the
spider a highly sought-after collector's
item a good condition spider will put a
serious dent in your bank account
restoring a spider can easily exceed the
cost of a new car
tracking down parts is like a treasure
hunt with no guarantee you'll ever find
what you're looking for only about 450
spiders still exist today
[Music]